Superhero casting news is everywhere, and it
changes at the drop of a hat. One day you
hear that they're adapting your favorite
comic book and the next day you hear
that Mr. Mom is cast as Batman or Gilbert
Grape is gonna be Spider-Man. Who could
have ever imagined that a 6'2" Australian
musical theatre actor was going to be
Weapon X. It's hard to picture him not
being Wolverine. Well, he almost wasn't.
DOUGRAY SCOTT AS WOLVERINE
It's pretty difficult to imagine anyone but Hugh
Jackman as Wolverine, but before filming
started on 2000's X-Men, Dougray Scott was
set to wear the claws. But scheduling
conflicts with Mission Impossible 2
meant director Bryan Singer went to the
next name on the list:
Jackman. Wolverine fans the world over
remain grateful.
JOHN KRASINSKI AS CAPTAIN AMERICA
Chris Evans has a
monopoly on comic characters, having been
cast as the Human Torch, Jake Jensen in
the adaptation of The Losers, and of
course, Captain America. But before Evans
got the job, the favorite was
John "Jim from The Office," Krasinski.
I haven't read my Marvel handbook in a while, but I'm pretty
sure sarcastically mugging for the
camera isn't one of Captain America's
super powers.
JAKE GYLLENHAAL AS SPIDER-MAN AND BATMAN
Tobey Maguire owned the role of Spider-Man in 2002's
film of the same name. But when his
health put him in danger of missing the sequel, director Sam Raimi cast
Jake Gyllenhaal. When Maguire was deemed
healthy enough to spin webs, Gyllenhaal
was sidelined. The actor also recently
revealed he tried, and failed, to secure
the Batman role that eventually went to
Christian Bale.
TOM CRUISE AS IRON MAN
Robert Downey Jr. might well be one of
the few actors who was born to play a
particular superhero. There was no doubt
that he was the right man for the Iron
Man job. Amazingly, Tom Cruise was first
in talks to wear the armor. He was in
talks with Marvel for years, but when the
time finally came to make the movie, he
lost interest.
MARLON WAYANS AS ROBIN
Director Tim Burton was slated to make a
third film in his Batman franchise. Comic
actor Marlon Wayans was cast as Robin,
and was set to get going after being
costume tested. But when Warner Bros. replaced Burton with Joel Schumacher,
the production started from zero. Wayan's contract was paid despite the fact that
the new movie cast Chris O'Donnell as
Robin.
NIC CAGE AS SUPERMAN
After he parted ways with Batman
Burton was planning on making Superman Lives starring Nicolas Cage with a
script by Clerks director Kevin Smith. Thankfully, it never got off the ground
As bad as the last few Superman movies have been, they're head and shoulders above
what this could have been.
BROOKE SHIELDS AS SUPERGIRL
On the subject of Superman, remember the bizarre Supergirl movie from 1984, with space wizards and
stuff? Before Helen Slater, Brooke Shields
was in talks to don the cape. The
director wanted to go with an unknown, so Shields was out.
ADRIANNE PALICKI AS WONDER WOMAN
This one technically counts. Even
though Adrianne Palicki actually filmed
the pilot, the David E. Kelley produced series was canned before it could even air. It's
too bad, since it could have been a
winner.
COMMON AS GREEN LANTERN
For a few years, Mad Max director George Miller was working on creating a Justice League
film, back when The Avengers was just a gleam in Disney's eye. Rapper/actor Common was
set to take on the role of Green Lantern
John Stewart, but the project was scrapped
and Common never got a ring.
BRADLEY COOPER AS GREEN LANTERN
On the subject of Green Lantern, Warner Bros. eventually went with a solo movie for
this character. Before Ryan Reynolds won the part, Bradley Cooper auditioned, and tanked it.
WB's loss, considering that Cooper
earned an Oscar nomination in 2012 and
Green Lantern tanked hard.
EMILY BLUNT AS BLACK WIDOW
If you have any doubts that Emily Blunt could have pulled off Black
Widow, we urge you to check out her
badass role as Rita in Live Die Repeat.
Blunt originally had the part of Black
Widow in Iron Man 2, but had to bow out
due to contractual obligations, and the
role was handed over to Scarlett
Johansson.
The movie she was obligated to do instead?
Gulliver's Travels. We feel for you Emily.
JIM CAVIEZEL AS CYCLOPS
Bryan Singer originally offered Caviezel the role of Cyclops, but Caviezel turned it down to
star in the movie Frequency instead. Sure, he missed out on being a cast mainstay in
some of the better X-Men movies, but he
also avoided being in Last Stand. So we'd say
that's a bullet dodged there. Also, Caviezel went on to act as everyone's favorite
superhero, Jesus!
LEONARDO DICAPRIO AS SPIDER-MAN
In the '90s, Sony got the rights to Spider-Man and wanted Leonardo
DiCaprio, fresh off the Titanic, to play
your friendly neighborhood wall crawler. He ultimately turned the role down,
and the project was reworked with Tobey Maguire as Spidey.
WILL SMITH AS SUPERMAN
Back in the long, long ago, Kevin Smith was set to direct a Superman movie. Producer Jon
Peters wanted Will Smith to portray
Clark Kent, but the movie never panned out.
When Bryan Singer started work on
Superman Returns, he offered the role to
Will Smith again. Smith turned down the
offer, saying "You mess up white people's
heroes in hollywood, you'll never work in
this town again."
BILL MURRAY AND EDDIE MURPHY AS BATMAN AND ROBIN
In 1983, before Tim Burton was signed on to direct Batman, Ivan Reitman was attached to direct. He wanted
to cast Bill Murray as Batman and
Eddie Murphy as Robin. In 1986, Tim Burton
was brought on to direct and had the
script rewritten, writing Robin out.
Thanks for watching!
Don't forget to like and subscribe if
you want more.